那給各位看個東西啊
這叫做CBS
這公開的喔
公開的
各位呢你可以上我的PB去
下載來看
這是元大的
那他這個CBS啊
CBS這樣子
我們來看一下
從最小價格到最高的
你看一下這邊喔
這邊有很多喔
然後這邊是他的年期
他這個數字喔
這數字呢
他意思說
你只要花這些錢喔
就可以買一張CBS
那買一張CBS他的禁止呢
大概大概都是多少都是10萬
所以呢你可能花個400塊有10萬塊
花個1000塊不到有10萬塊價值
那400塊有10萬塊價值相當於250倍
你有250倍槓桿
這麼誇張的槓桿
但是沒有250倍槓桿的風險
那四百塊你就賭極元一個春天
這九個月極元要噴出去對不對
這種噴有時候它的倍數很誇張
我們有看過那種噴兩三百倍的
啊這些錢有多少呢
這些錢對你的原因
你自己想想看啊
你過年的時候
你的刮刮樂有沒有刮的比這些多
然後呢
這些價格目前還不一定很便宜
那有一天它可能變得超便宜
哪一天呢
哪一天喔就是在崩盘那一天他就会变成便宜那除了崩盤那一天變很便宜外呢有些標的呢我們還可以來做什麼
我們還可以來做
動態避險
那什麼叫動態避險
這個化碳5呢
他就是一個適合做動態避險的標的
就是我們可以買CBS
然後呢用期貨來做這個動態避險
動態避險就是
你就上面空在底下補這樣子
上面空幾下補
上面公家就這樣子
各位
CBS頂多就歸零而已
好不好
不用擔心
400塊錢歸零
你不用太糾結
頂多歸零
那有沒有可能常歸零
對 常常歸零
但是你至少有很長一段時間
可以陪著他有可能走一大大行情
動態避險我覺得很好玩
其實我
我是沒時間的
不然我真的覺得動態避險真的是
對你好好學 它是一個不會讓你賠錢
東海幣錢會賠就股票沒動
好不好
所以東海幣錢你不能選台灣大這種
這種牛皮股
除了這種牛皮股以外
其實很多都很適合做東海幣錢
那東海幣錢就是
你可以做無腦當衝
什麼叫無腦當衝
就是你根本不用看盤
早上出門前把那個
買賣的價位全部掛出去
你就出去遊山玩水
回來再看成交就好
那你一邊爬山你也可以一邊看成交
有成交你還可以繼續掛單
沒成交就沒事
這是萬一筆錢